what is our relationship to the sacred I
believe that can be summed up in the
words of Joseph Campbell our
relationship to the sacred is one in
which we are beheld in aesthetic arrest
right these are the moments that take
our breath away transitory enchanted
moments in which man must have held his
breath moments in which we are compelled
into aesthetic contemplations we barely
understand or desire face to face with
something can measure it to our capacity
for wonder so our relationship with the
sacred is our relationship to what
Michael Pollan describes as a sense of
first sight unencumbered by knowingness
the putrid nodding resignation have been
theirs and seem as in the adult mind
that jaded miss that sedated miss that
pretends to have seen it all before that
pretends to know it all that has leap
leap frogged
to the conclusion of whatever is showing
up so that nothing is ever engaging our
relationship with the sacred is what
Timothy Leary described as experiencing
afresh afresh the hardly bearable barely
bearable ecstasy
of Direct Energy exploding on our nerve
and it is hurling ourselves into the
abyss our relationship with the sacred
is our relationship with the timeless
the sacred is the answer to the problem
of human existence and what is the
problem of human existence our finitude
right the explicit awareness that you're
a breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and ultimately no more
significant than a lizard or a potato
according to Sheldon Solomon this is the
worm at the core this is the faint
disquiet that haunts our dreams to have
emerged from nothing to have a named
consciousness of self deep inner feeling
an excruciating inner yearning for life
and for self expressions and yet with
all this yet to die
human beings said Ernest Becker aren't
quite the predicament we have the mental
capacity to ponder the infinite
seemingly capable of anything mainlining
space and time through the optic nerve
yet were simultaneously housed in heart
pumping breath gasping decaying bodies
we are simultaneously gods and worms and
in response to this existential waking
anihilation right this realization that
we are mortal beings the only response
is the religious impulse the only
response is a contention with the sacred
which is to again contend with the
unknown and strive to make it known it
requires absolution it requires apathy
OSIS it requires ecstatic surrender if
it requires letting go it requires a
leap of faith right absolute unmixed
attention a form
prayer if you cannot submit you cannot
die but if you cannot die you cannot be
reborn our relationship with the sacred
is a bliss crucifixion it's a holy
moment it's the time we see the world in
a grain of sand as Blake said in heaven
in a wild flower it's when we get to
hold infinity in the palms of our hands
it's when we get to hold eternity in an
hour the sacred is all we have the
sacred is all there is the sacred is
what we've been looking for
[Music]